>>> IN GEORGIA, MORE CONTROVERSY
FOR HERSCHEL WALKER.
THE WOMAN WHO SAID TO THE SENATE
NOMINEE PAID FOR HER ABORTION IN
2009, SAYS HE URGED HER TO
TERMINATE A SECOND PREGNANCY BUT
SHE CHOSE NOT TO.
AS A WEATHER, HE SAYS HE DOES
NOTHING AND DOES WHAT THE COURTS
SAY AND THAT'S IT.
SHE ADDS, YOU HAVE TO BE HELD
RESPONSIBLE.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO RUN FOR
OFFICE, YOU NEED TO CONTROL YOUR
LIFE.
THE NEW ALLEGATION COMES AS WE
LEARNED THE CAMPAIGN FIRED ITS
POLITICAL DIRECTOR.
JAMES CARVILLE ADVISED BILL
CLINTON'S 1992 CAMPAIGN.
AND ALSO WITH US, ASSISTANT TO
PRESIDENT GEORGE BUSH, SCOTT
JENNINGS.
JAMES, HOW MUCH TROUBLE IS
HERSCHEL WALKER IN RIGHT NOW?
>> HE WOULD BE IN A TON OF
TROUBLE.
ABORTION IS A COMPLICATED ISSUE.
HE DID THE HONORABLE THING, TO
PAY FOR THE FIRST ABORTION.
HE'S GOT FOUR CHILDREN THAT HE'S
NOT INVOLVED IN THEIR LIFE.
WE KNOW WHAT JESUS THOUGHT ABOUT
THAT.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT HE THOUGHT
ABOUT GUNS.
BUT WE KNOW WHAT HE THOUGHT
ABOUT HARMING CHILDREN.
THAT'S TYING A STONE AROUND A
NECK AND THROWING THEM OUT TO
SEA.
GIVE ME A BREAK.
THE MASSIVE AMOUNT OF HYPOCRISY
IS BEYOND BELIEF.
ABORTION IS BAD ENOUGH.
JUST ANOTHER REPUBLICAN
HYPOCRITE.
AND THE HARM OF CHILDREN CANNOT
BE FORGIVEN.
IT'S DISGUSTING, JIM.
>> SCOTT, YOUR RESPONSE?
THERE IS HYPOCRISY HERE.
>> HERSCHEL WALKER IS NOT A
PERFECT VESSEL.
REPUBLICANS IN GEORGIA WOULD
TELL YOU THEY DON'T THINK
WARKNOCK IS, EITHER.
YOU HAVE TWO IMPERFECT VESSELS.
YOU KNOW, WHAT ELSE IS GOING ON?
THE AVERAGE REPUBLICAN IS GOING
TO SAY, I DON'T NECESSARILY
AGREE, WITH HIS PERSONAL
CHOICES.
BUT I DON'T LIKE JOE BIDEN OR
WARKNOCK VOTING WITH JOE BIDEN.
HE IS SPENDING A LOT OF NEGATIVE
PRESS RIGHT NOW.
I BELIEVE THAT THE REPUBLICAN
ESTABLISHMENT, THE COMMITTEES,
WILL STICK WITH HIM.
THEY THINK THEY'RE IN THE RACE
IN GEORGIA.
THEY'RE TAKING A LOOK AT IT AND
WON'T REALLY KNOW UNTIL TUESDAY
OR WEDNESDAY, WHEN THEY CAN GET
SOLID DAA BACK ON IT.
I BELIEVE HERSCHEL CAN RIDE IT
OUT.
>> JAMES, BEFORE THE LATEST
STORY, REPUBLICANS TRIED TO
DEFEND HERSCHEL WALKER.
YOU HEARD A DEFENSE RIGHT THERE.
LISTEN TO WHAT NEWT GINGRICH HAD
TO SAY.
>> I TALKED TO HERSCHEL ABOUT
THIS MORNING.
I'VE KNOWN HERSCHEL A GOOD
WHILE.
I THINK HE'S A REMARKABLE
PERSON.
HE'S THE MOST IMPORTANT SENATE
CANDIDATE IN THE COUNTRY.
HE WILL DO MORE TO CHANGE THE
SENATE, BY THE PRESENCE, BY HIS
CONFIDENCE, HIS DEEP COMMITMENT
TO CHRIST.
HE'S BEEN THROUGH A LONG, TOUGH
PERIOD.
HE HAD A LOT OF CONCUSSIONS
COMING OUT OF FOOTBALL.
HE SUFFERED PTSD.
>> NEWT GINGRICH USING THE
CONCUSSION EXCUSE.
>> AM I A FLAWED HUMAN BEING?
OF COURSE I AM.
YOU AND EVERYBODY ELSE?
YES.
CHILD NEGLECT, WITHOUT ASKING
FOR REDEMPTION, DENYING THAT HIS
CHILDREN EXIST, TRYING TO CHOKE
ONE OF THEIR MOTHERS, PUTTING A
GUN TO THEIR HEAD.
YOU PUT NEWT GINGRICH'S PICTURE
UP THERE?
THERE'S SOMETHING WRONG WITH
THIS.
SOMETHING WRONG.
ANY HUMAN BEING IS FLAWED.
ANYBODY CAN HAVE A DIFFICULT
DECISION VIS-A-VIS A PREGNANCY.
IF THAT'S FINE WITH SCOTT
JENNINGS AND NEWT GINGRICH,
THAT'S THE MODERN REPUBLICAN
PARTY, THAT SHOULD BE EXPOSED.
>> CAN I RESPOND?
MR. CARLISLE I THINK IS
UNFAMILIAR WITH RAPHAEL'S RECORD
ON THIS.
HE HAS A WIFE SAYING HE WAS ME
NEGLECTFUL TO HER.
POSSIBLY ABUSIVE.
I STARTED MY ANSWER, THAT BOTH
OF THESE GUYS ARE IMPERFECT
VESSELS.
THERE'S OTHER ISSUES IN THE
CAMPAIGN THAT PEOPLE ARE GOING
TO TAKE INTO ACCOUNT.
WALKER'S ISSUES ARE GOING TO
WEIGH ON MINDS.
AND SO ARE WARNOCKS.
A HEAD OF LETTUCE IS $1,000 A
HEAD.
WE HAVE MAJOR PROBLEMS AND
AMERICANS ARE NOT ONLY FOCUSING
ON THE PERSONAL ISSUES OF TWO
FLAWED CANDIDATES.
>> THERE'S GRADEUATIONS OF BEING
FLAWED.
EVERYBODY IS FLAWED.
YOU'RE TELLING ME, THIS MAN
NEGLECTS HIS CHILDREN AND
DOESN'T ACKNOWLEDGE THEM AND
THAT'S HAPPENED OVERTIME.
GET REAL.
IS THERE ANYTHING -- ANY BOTTOM
TO THE REPUBLICAN PARTY?
ANY BOTTOM TO SOMEBODY THAT THEY
WON'T SUPPORT?
YOU TROT NEWT GINGRICH, THE
GREAT MORAL AUTHORITY OF ALL.
AND HE HAS SEVERE MENTAL ISSUES,
HE WOULD BE A GREAT SENATOR.
I HAVE SYMPATHY FOR MENTAL
PATIENTS, THEY NEED TO BE GIVEN
DRUGS AND TREATED.
THEY DON'T NEED TO BE IN THE
SENATE.
THAT'S AN ABSURD ARGUMENT.
AND IT'S ABSURD TO SAY WE'RE ALL
FLAWED HUMAN BEINGS AND STOP
RIGHT THERE.
THAT'S RIDICULOUS.
THAT'S A RIDICULOUS ARGUMENT.
>> LET ME MOVE ON TO THE
WISCONSIN SENATE RACE.
THAT COULD HINGE ON THAT RACE,
AS WELL.
JOHNSON AND BARNES.
THE TWO SPARRED OVER THE ISSUE
OF FUNDING THE POLICE.
LET'S WATCH.
>> A RECORD OF WANTING TO DEFUND
THE POLICE.
AND I KNOW HE DOESN'T
NECESSARILY SAY THAT WORD.
A LONG HISTORY OF PEOPLE
SUPPORTING THE EFFORT TO DEFUND.
>> HE MENTIONED POLICE OFFICERS.
THAT BEING SAID, I'M SURE HE
DIDN'T HAVE THE SAME INTERACTION
WITH 140 OFFICERS THAT WERE
INJURED IN THE JANUARY 6th
INSURRECTION.
ONE OFFICER WAS STABBED WITH A
STAKE.
ANOTHER CRUSHED BETWEEN A DOOR.
ANOTHER HIT IN THE HEAD WITH A
FIRE EXTINGUISHER.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE 140
OFFICERS HE LEFT BEHIND BECAUSE
OF AN INSURRECTION HE SUPPORTED.
>> I IMMEDIATELY AND FORCEFULLY
AND HAVE REPEATEDLY CONDEMNED IT
AND CONDEMNED IT STRONGLY.
I'VE ALSO CONDEMNED THE 570
RIOTS THAT OCCURRED DURING THE
SUMMER.
SO MANY PEOPLE IGNORE THOSE.
>> DOES THAT MAKE YOU WINCE A
LITTLE BIT?
>> THE CRIME ISSUE IS RISING.
REPUBLICANS ARE PUTTING IT TO
GOOD USE IN SEVERAL CAMPAIGNS.
WISCONSIN IS ONE.
BARNES IS ONE OF THE MOST
LIBERAL DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATES ON
THE CRIME ISSUE.
IT'S WORKING AGAINST FETTERMAN
AND BEASLEY IN NORTH CAROLINA.
PEOPLE KNOW IT.
THIS IS RISING AMONG VOTERS.
THAT'S WHY REPUBLICANS ARE USING
IT, THIS IDEA OF DEFUNDING THE
POLICE, REDIRECTING THE MONEY,
WHATEVER YOU WANT TO CALL IT.
THEY CAN'T RUN AWAY FROM IT IN
THE MIDDLE OF A NATIONAL CRIME
WAVE.
YOU HAVE STORIES IN EVERY MAJOR
MEDIA MARKET IN THE COUNTRY
ABOUT CRIME.
I UNDERSTAND THE BARNES
DEFLECTION THERE.
OVER ALL, THE ISSUE OF PUBLIC
SAFETY AND FEELING SAFE WHEN YOU
LEAVE YOUR HOUSE OR PLACE OF
BUSINESS OR TAKE YOUR KIDS WHERE
YOU HAVE TO TAKE THEM, IT'S A
MAJOR PROBLEM.
AND NO AMOUNT OF DEFLECTION BY
BARNES IS GOING TO RUN AWAY FROM
HIS LIBERAL RECORD ON THIS
TOPIC.
>> IS THAT HOW DEMOCRATS SHOULD
GO AFTER REPUBLICANS WHO ARE
INVOLVED IN ATTEMPTING TO
OVERTURN THE ELECTION RESULTS?
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> I THINK MR. BARNES MISSPOKE
ON DEFUND THE POLICE.
I THINK HE ACKNOWLEDGED THAT.
RON JOHNSON HAS ENDORSED THE
RICK SCOTT PLAN TO GET RID OF
SOCIAL SECURITY AND MEDICARE.
HE ENDORSED THE PLAN THAT WOULD
RAISE TAXES SIGNIFICANTLY ON
LOWER AND MIDDLE INCOME
AMERICANS.
YOU SAY, WHAT I SAID WAS UNWISE.
YOU CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THIS.
THIS IS WHAT RON JOHNSON IS.
TO SUNSET SOCIAL SECURITY.
TO SUNSET MEDICARE.
TO TAX HOTEL MATE.
YOU MAKE AN ERROR, YOU ADMIT IT
AND GO TO A POSITION THAT HE
TOOK THAT I THINK IS UTTER